all right so the time has come for my
top ten favorite movies of 2012 there
are a couple things to know before going
into this I haven't seen every movie
that came out in 2012 I heard silver
linings playbook and works to being a
wallflower just fantastic movies but I
haven't seen them so they won't be on
this top 10 list I'm not saying they
would be on the top 10 list if I did see
them because we don't live in a parallel
universe where I know the answer to that
and I won't see zero dark thirty until
January so technically it'll be a 2013
movie for me and these are not reviews
nor are they objective this is my top
ten list if ever there's a time for a
reviewer to give complete biased opinion
it's a top ten list that being said
let's get started number 10 starting off
at number 10 is wreckit-ralph there's
usually an animation somewhere near the
bottom of the top 10 list this year it's
wreck-it Ralph because I'm a big
videogame fanatic and wreck-it Ralph was
really completely enjoyable one could
argue it's the best video game based
movie out there that's actually an
animation that's not really based off a
specific video game wreck-it Ralph paid
homage to the video game classics of the
80s and 90s lay the cards ride that
could have a sweet franchise like Toy
Story buffer games and coming in at
number nine this was the movie I was
like all right if I can really help
myself this will be on my top 10 list
and it's cabin in the woods because
cabin in the woods isn't really a horror
movie it's a movie that deconstructs
horror movies to the bone marrow if
you're a fan of horror movies or movies
in general you should at least check out
Cabin in the Woods best of its kind for
sure number eight coming in at number
eight is Daniel day-lewis as President
Lincoln Lincoln was completely badass it
showed that Spielberg didn't get lost
somewhere in Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull a guy can make really good
personal movies he showed that with War
Horse and he gave it to us again with
Lincoln number seven now I have a funny
relationship with this movie the first
time I saw it I was like yeah it was
really good second time I saw it I was
like yeah this is great
and that's the Hobbit and unexpected
journey to some people the 48 frames a
second effect really throws them off
other people find it really engrossing
but the point is even though the Hobbit
and unexpected journey isn't as good as
Lord of the Rings the Lord of the Rings
movies being my favorite movies of all
time very few movies are as good but the
negatives of The Hobbit and unexpected
journey are completely eclipsed by the
effect of going back to middle-earth
which this movie does like a champ
vercinix coming in at number six Ben
Affleck shows us upon all the jokes
about him in the 90s now he's a really
established director and that is Argo it
is ludicrous that the story of Argo
actually happened that's just crazy to
me it's well acted well directed
all-around well-executed it's the most
exciting movie where no one gets shot
I'd admit that something boy now we're
at the top five this is where the heavy
hitters start coming in coming in at
number five is Skyfall this is the Bond
movie where they were like all right
after decades upon decades of content
and a few years of trying to reboot we
finally found the happy medium that's a
great Bond movie it still has that dark
cinematic realistic element that people
are just doing crazy over these days but
still has its Bond element it was
perfect in that sense number four number
four is the reason I'm actually getting
you my top ten now I would have gotten
it to you earlier but I was like ah
there's still django unchained out there
and i think i need to see that before i
make a top ten list and I'm completely
glad I did this is one of those movies
that gets better and better the more you
think about it just think about the
dialogue and the shootout scenes and the
concept and the acting and you're like
yeah django unchained is just what I
love about Tarantino no first coming in
at number three was Marvel's like five
to six year plan we've seen it building
to the Avengers for so long and then it
finally hits and usually a movie like
that would disappoint to no end but the
Avengers was completely badass they got
the perfect director Joss Whedon to have
a plethora of characters and make them
all relevant all of that with having a
good villain yeah the Avengers is up
there number two number two and number
one I flipped back and forth I was like
alright this is number one this is
number two this number two this is
number one number two was one of the
coolest original sci-fi I've seen in the
past decade and that is looper I figured
it'd be a simple Joseph gordon-levitt's
going after Bruce blows he needs to kill
him the end but it's not like that it's
actually a lot deeper than that some of
the time elements you think about you're
like oh wait that doesn't really make
sense because in all right time they do
a good job of being like hey stay on
point the movies awesome and you're like
oh yeah it is I'm gonna I'm gonna let
all those weird time things that I'm
thinking about that Star Trek taught me
throughout the years go away because I
enjoy looper so much and looper had an
awesome breakout performance from this
kid actor in the movie who's it's a kid
in a movie that's not annoying as [ __ ]
never a bad thing as far as I'm
concerned that'll get
you a few spots up let alone number two
no one and you haven't seen it on my top
ten list yet so either you're thinking
to yourself wait that's not in the top
ten list at all or is just going to
naturally be number one and number one
is the Dark Knight Rises yet my fanboy
ISM is completely showing at this point
but I don't care it's my top ten list
and as it is a completely non objective
top ten list of what I love most this
year it's Batman I love the villain I
thought Anne Hathaway was great as
Catwoman I loved the lesson behind it
which is like oh yeah you want to fix
your city sweet you're going to totally
destroy yourself doing it I've seen that
in a couple movies before but the Dark
Knight Rises was a great concluding
chapter to a great trilogy I had 4 back
ok when you can understand every word in
this movie and not need subtitles to do
it you just feel accomplished and you
feel obligated to put it as your number
one that's not why really but you say
the movie has its conveniences
absolutely I think most any movie on
this list does I'm just saying it
doesn't change the fact that when I
think of the movie of 2012 I'm going to
think of the Dark Knight Rises in that
The Dark Knight Rises number one for me
right so those are my top 10 favorite
movies of 2012 and yes for every top 10
best list there is a top 10 worst list
that's coming to you would be a little
easier than a top 10 list cuz there were
so many good movies this year this is
easily the most difficult top 10 movie
list I've done yet if there's a person
out there who hasn't done their top 10
movie list yet it's because they have a
list of movies with scribbles and cliff
notes and arrows and they're just like I
don't know that this can easily be a top
15 list 2012 is definitely the best year
of movies that has happened since I've
been doing YouTube videos and so now
it's in your hands my friends what are
your top 10 favorite movies of 2012
make a list put it below or make a video
and put it as a video response however
you do it I'd love to hear from you and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you